I think most people will think
Payday loans are not the best choice for loans
It is likely to be for people who are in desperate need of money
High fees
What I want to do in this section is
Explain what is going on and do some math calculations
Let you really understand the interest they charge
How unreasonable
Hypothesis using this method
I need to buy a beautiful birthday present for my wife tomorrow.
I need to borrow $500.
So I have to borrow $500.
I infer
For a certain gift, most people will not borrow money.
They may be paying rent or paying utility bills.
Or borrow money from food or something else
But whatever your reason is
You need to borrow $500 to infer
There is not much money in your bank account.
Otherwise you won't go to the payday borrower.
They said ok, Sal, we are willing to lend you $500.
About your credit status and related content
We will not do a thorough investigation
But we want to know a few things
First we want to know your pay slip and payday
They want to see your pay slip
They want to know when you are paying
We call it your payday
They may need the most recent bank statement
The reason they want these things is
They want to know what you know
Even if your credit is very poor
Then you will get your salary
Or payday in two weeks
You will get paid from the boss
Then you can repay the $500 arrears
To ensure this
So they want to make sure you have a job
Get $1,000 every two weeks on your payslip
Or $2,000
So that you have the ability to pay
Maybe you earn $1,500 every two weeks.
They like to see these
Maybe from the day you borrowed
Your payday is two weeks
So two weeks from today
And your bank statement shows
$1,500 more in your account
You pay for rent to buy food
Then the account balance is close to zero
Then it rose to 1500
But they want to see
This $1,500 is paid regularly.
They said that you know
We will lend you 500 today.
You need to write a check
Not writing a check for $500
But write a debit for every $100
You need to pay an extra $25
Extra 25 dollars
At first you will say that is good.
25% interest rate
Higher interest rates than credit cards
But this is not a 25% annual interest rate. This is a 25% interest rate for two weeks.
At the end of the video
I will compare
What is the adult interest rate?
What is the effective annual interest rate?
These numbers are not outrageous
These are actually typical for payday loans.
So if I borrow $500
I have to return $500 in two weeks.
Plus $25 for every $100
So I borrowed $500.
I will have to pay an extra $125 for 25 times 5
I will write a check for 500 plus $125.
That would be $625
Obviously not so much money in my account right now.
Otherwise I won't go to a payday loan
I want to do my hands on the date.
I will postpone the date of this check.
I will write the date
Suppose this is the beginning of the month
Or the assumption is January 1st
I will write on January 16th, which year is the year.
I have postponed it for two weeks from today.
In the next two weeks
Then I signed the check
I write a payday loan
I wrote $625 and so on.
Then here is some information
I gave this check to them.
They will say that we will not honor it
We just keep this small and cute check
You can make a choice when your payday is up.
You can come to us and pay us $625 in cash.
Then we will return this unpaid cheque to you.
Or if you don't show up
We will honor this loan
So there is always one of these two things that will happen.
But in fact
If you don't lie to them
They will basically charge you $625.
You think this is risky for the lender.
Because the borrower has the potential to repay very low
Obviously the borrower has nowhere to go.
So they are not good at managing their property
But they will do their best to ensure
Once payday is coming
Once you get a salary from your boss
Before you pay rent, utilities and food
They can get the money first
That is the basic concept of payday loans
Now let's start talking about this may not be a good way.
You should have an understanding of this
Because we pay a 25% interest rate every two weeks.
Not every year
We think about what it means based on the annual interest rate.
Suppose I pay $25 for every $100.
Is the real 25% interest rate
When you say a percentage, this root means 100 pairs.
100 years in a century
So literally means every 100
25 percent literally means 25% interest rate
Or we write it down in a customary way
This is a 25% interest rate every two weeks.
If we only calculate a simple APR
a simple annual interest rate
For this question you may want to watch the next video.
In order to understand it with a 25% interest rate
Then multiply by the number of cycles in a year
There are 52 weeks a year but this is the rate every two weeks.
So instead of multiplying it by 52
We will multiply it by half of 52 and multiply by 26
So multiply by 26 times every year for 26 two weeks
This is 25% every two weeks
When you get out
This is equivalent to letting us calculate with a calculator
I will multiply these numbers
I wrote a decimal point of 25 times and 26 equals 650.
The annual interest rate we pay is 650%
If you think of a credit card company
Charge you a ten or twenty percent interest rate
Already a fairly high interest rate
And this is 650%
One order of magnitude higher than credit card interest
Or higher than an order of magnitude
So this is really a crazy annual interest rate.
This is just the result of our multiplication by 26.
Simple annual interest rate
This is not a valid annual interest rate
Or the one that is really mathematically correct
In order to get the loan we actually need to spend
You may want to see this
If you let this be calculated according to compound interest
Can you imagine if you are a lender?
And you keep lending money
You actually have to follow the compound interest
If you lend the interest you got from the last person
And lending the same interest rate
To calculate a valid annual interest rate
You do compound interest calculation 1.25 26th power
26 cycles per year
How much will it be?
Calculate the 26th power of 1.25
Then we got this crazy number
We have to subtract 1 from it
That won't have much impact on our mathematical results.
Lose 1 we got me to make it clearer
Essentially this is 329 times our borrowing
So if there is a 1 here, it is 100%
I made it clear
This number is quite high
hard to imagine
If you use this interest rate to let the money go to compound interest
Generally at least let you roll out the principal
This may be correct or maybe incorrect but the actual lender
If they can lend at such an interest rate, they can roll out the principal.
Will get 329 times the principal
If you want to write a percentage, it will
Is 32987 32987%
Or one year later
Essentially you will have to return the borrower
330 times the amount of borrowing
Obviously they won't make you like that
But let you know
How absurd this interest rate is
I mean you may have heard the word loan shark.
In the past, usury refers to any kind of interest rate.
But now in our cultural environment
We only refer to unreasonable interest rates.
This threshold may be different for different people.
Some people will say that 20% interest rate per year is unreasonable.
Or 30% or 40%
But I think everyone will agree
No matter how you look at 650% or 33000%
These are usury loans that are unreasonable interest rates.
So unless it’s about life
Otherwise, avoid borrowing such a payday loan.